so on sunday when i started preparing
our monday show i didn't realize that
this would be the week of the burner
phone where burner phones becomes a
topic just about every single day but it
is and we have hilarious new information
about burner phones and it actually
comes from trump's former national
security adviser john bolton who
appeared on cnn yesterday and said trump
not only used burner phones all the time
he used the term burner phones all the
time so let's back up and kind of give
you the genesis of this entire lie the
first thing that happened was that we
learned that the call logs turned over
to the january 6th trump riot committee
by the trump white house were missing
about seven and a half hours of calls
and one of the things that was
speculated was well okay they might have
just deleted the records of what
happened on the phones during those
seven and a half hours but also trump
might have been using the phones of
associates during those seven and a half
hours or he might have been using burner
phones these disposable phones that you
use and then you throw away okay
trump first and foremost immediately put
out a statement saying i have no idea
what a burner phone is to the best of my
knowledge i have never even heard the
term
and i immediately told you
that seems like an obvious lie
just doesn't really make any sense that
that's not a term trump would be
familiar with
the next day
we got a statement
written statement from john bolton
trump's former national security adviser
to cbs news and the statement was
i heard trump use the phrase burner
phones multiple times and trump
absolutely knows what it means
makes perfect sense it's just not
believable that donald trump doesn't
know what a burner phone is obviously
trump knows and uses the term
but it was just kind of a written
statement we now have an interview of
donald trump's former national security
adviser john bolton on cnn saying he he
used the term all the time and you know
what i believe john bolton and i'll tell
you why in a second take a listen to
this report the house select committee
investigating the january 6th
insurrection is looking into whether
former president trump used so-called
burner phones during a seven-hour gap in
official white house call records during
the riot during the attack on the
capitol in response trump said in a
statement quote i have no idea what a
burner phone is to the best of my
knowledge i have never even heard of of
the term joining us now is former trump
national security adviser john bolton uh
sir what do you say to that
well i can't understand what the the
former president is uh is saying because
i heard him use the term
burner phone a number of times it's
hardly like it's some obscure highly
classified uh a set of words yeah it's
not like key bump about cocaine key
bumps like madison cawthorne used guys
everybody knows what a burner phone is
the criminal gangs in the united states
use burner phones terrorists around the
world use bone burner phones and as i
say i i heard he mention it so you'll
have to you'll have to guess what the
reason for his statement is
he said
quote
burner phones in in conversation
he did yes it was a term he actually
kind of liked he'd say you know they
have these burner phones
uh uh
so you know it's uh the president former
president's uh acquaintance with the
truth is often very casual i think
bolton's telling the truth guys i mean
listen bolton is a terrible warmongering
neocon but he's clearly the more
trustworthy one here first of all logic
tell us trump's constant logic tells us
trump's constantly
first of all trying to hide records of
the things that he's doing is it likely
that the term burner phone has never
come up in his trying to hide records of
the things that he does secondly trump's
constantly talking about gang activity
in the united states undocumented
immigrants trafficking ms-13 etc do we
whatever your opinion is about trump's
view on immigration do we really believe
that the term burner phones hasn't been
regularly used in trump's discussions
with officials about immigration and
gangs and so on it's just not believable
and as horrible a person as john bolton
is
architect of the iraq war i mean
horrible horrible guy
in this particular disagreement
it's very clear who's telling the truth
by the way this is kind of funny too
there's even a picture now that has been
found
where it looks like trump
has a potential burner phone with him
there's these pictures and we're showing
one to our audience where trump has
phones wrapped in newspapers when he's
getting on and off the golf course and
again the speculation is this is a
really weird way to carry a phone that
these are phones trump is handed to make
individual phone calls and then they're
just given back to whoever wrapped up in
the newspaper and thrown into the trash
that's speculative that's speculative
but there are a number of these pictures
so why does it matter well it matters
because as usual trump is lying about
everything down to the absolute smallest
detail that's why we care about it
that's why it matters and uh he's lying
when it comes to hiding his phone
activity on january 6th he's lying when
it comes to what he was doing during
that time and his motivations and his
reaction and his opinion about what
happened on january 6th and he's
obviously lying about the little things
as well like burner phone i don't know
i've never heard of that that's never
it's quite frankly
it's like a cocaine user
saying i don't know what a key bump is
i've never that's never that's not a
term i've ever heard come on guys it's
just not believable and we are not
rehabilitating john bolton's image we
are not doing anything other than saying
in this particular case
it's obvious to me
that bolton's the guy that's telling the
truth i'm really excited that uh one of
our sponsors today is helix sleep i
sleep on a helix mattress at home i
absolutely love it and that's why i
reached out to them about sponsoring the
david pakman show buying a mattress in
the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free when you go to the link right
underneath this video